we went to a meditation retreat didn't
we
it was amazing but it was really
difficult for anyone who is considering
doing a meditation retreat it's really
[ __ ] hard why do you buy a map book
rather than a PC anyone use a PC for
three minutes and it'll answer so I've
been rear-ended twice in the last month
in a car in a car we shave got in a car
yeah you know what it is as soon as you
feel that impact the senses it's not
like I'm gonna it is just all of the
admin flow this is why you shouldn't be
allowed on plane unless you've got an
iPhone and everything would be much
simpler because the people who've made
bad decisions will be confined to the
where they live who finally got unto the
life hack of getting a haircut at home
haven't you yeah half before the
hairdresser went round to his she texted
me to say hang on a second I'm about to
go around to this person's house that
I've never met before I probably should
think about my own safety is he easy a
weirdo
and I'm like
ladies and gentlemen look who's joined
me again Johnny and Yusef from propane
fitness calm it's been a long while
welcome back welcome thank you
welcome to us so today we're doing a
catch-up episode no agenda no topics in
hand other than just what's been going
on in our lives recently so what's been
going on in your life recently Jonathan
what have you been doing this is a hot
potato
there you go see yeah I have been on TV
today love Island I play look line the
current scene I think right love Island
anything worse you know there are worse
things as manager is so why were you on
TV God so I was basically put on TV by
someone who wanted to go on pointless
but didn't have a partner so if you if
you don't watch pointless it's a it's
aired I think it's six days a week in
the UK you ever seen points no you
probably some have not been to that I
was in the ER right there so that was
very much like me before I realized like
on the train on the way down I should
probably watch an episode of this so a
hot spot but quickly getting up yes and
there's a man yes so it was in there in
like the the warm-up so you arrived I'm
in the room and the woman said sometimes
people get to this point they haven't
seen an episode of the show that is a
common problem then it's not like
because I know no nobody it only because
she was making that out to be at least
it's not that bad you know at least it's
not about ridiculous and you're just
like because it cuz when you're there
you're in that world and everyone's
there taking it very seriously in the
fact that you think it's all pointless
and stupid pointless yeah
isn't funny and it's not funny of you
either because you're about to go on
national TV and potentially be may look
like an absolute prick but it actually
went alright laughs you won right can
you tell us about your jumper this ya
know said I legit oh so I called Johnny
day the day before he had to go down in
that we survey of you said I got a
contour I'm in Primark I'm having a
night
I wasn't allowed to wear any of my
jumpers and I have to get a plain orange
green or blue jumper kaboom
I couldn't be green so the blue guy
seems likes posting a very specific blue
okay just why it was the blue that I was
wearing and you only have navy so you're
not there's the biggest problem is
you're not allowed anything with a logo
yeah and you look like an embroidery
that's three centimeters tall
like visible only from up close but was
too much so all my clothes I don't mean
tucked in you yeah so can they not just
stick that on top of the light depends
on the position the server's name tags
also a very fine line that the name tags
up because I'm taller than what was
yours of you your belly button yeah it
was like I was it's just not he's um but
yeah it was it was fine it was quite
stressful I came across very well thanks
I'm excited and anyone who has not seen
Jonny's episode of pointless it's now
available on BBC iPlayer within the next
29 days hurry up you need to go and
watch it now do you know what episode
number is now 12
thank you is that joke no although if I
might be say your elbow a link in the
show notes oh come watch Youssef what's
been going on in your life what's we
know I've just been deep in the work
cave unfortunately it's not you can see
from my pasty complexion
I'm racially Arab and you wouldn't know
I've been sucked over yeah so I've got
my finals coming up so in three months
time
if I pass then doctor doctor you could
be you you could be looking at someone's
ailments so there's semi finals now so
these are the semi finals right and you
get your qualifying defiant into the
tournament yeah Premiership if there's a
round-robin two premierships
are you showing you're showing off with
your double pitch you know I've got a
slightly tight left hip what happens
when I still miss yeah I've seen you on
that podcast with the Giant
there was someone who covered it under
the video saying why is that blonde guy
so big yeah I'd be like cuz you were
just like yeah that was when you were a
peak 105 kilos as well as I said that
the interesting thing so there's another
episode of pointless right this yet to
air so I thought was gonna be on tonight
it wasn't in tonight's there's obviously
a gap because it was a gap in filming of
like three months in that time I think I
gained about five kilos and grew my hair
yes they were about to run them day by
day because they say like try not to
change your appearance and I'm sorry
mate has just commenced on project top
not I just used up awake well in the
interim it with my god Johnny
hello welcome what do you do in your
like I'm an online fitness coach in
there like well you work in a gym at
home and then you tell people no pajamas
yeah
one of the lads the other day had a
Skype interview for a placement and one
of the boys he lives with took a photo
from the side and he'd gone full suit
from the waist up and boxes The Trevor
McDonald yeah what's been happening in
Chris inside of Chris inside of inside
of the first conversation oh we went to
a we did it what is there any water as a
pube I don't think it's for you maybe
it's one of my beard house since unlike
most likely it's most likely yes i it's
funny how you just assume sure hair if
you use your eyes it's more likely to be
saying there's a pube is very you know
yeah genes called pubes
I mean but up yeah think so another year
nine thing wearing the chain with you
all the time do you know what I mean you
know school trousers clip it on and then
it comes back and then you were like
there's a new pocket yeah
people used to wear South Park
characters on the jesusí remember oh
it's like it's nice to have a little
cami a little
Kyah Kyah SEVIS fan flat hair and then
yeah the kid off ways shot ways well wet
look shockwaves over there people yeah
we went to a meditation retreat didn't
we we did we did it one day in hwadam
monastery called Hannam Harnam a routine
nigiri in BellSouth say beautiful place
it was amazing but it was really
difficult for anyone who is considering
doing a meditation retreat it's really
[ __ ] hard physical part it's just
staying awake really being being said
entry but also staying awake about
having your eyes closed like Advil
anyone over the phone it's an odd blend
of so where did he sit outside inside so
we did it pretty much 50/50 of either
walking or feel out as in outside
meditation versus feeling sitting so a
satyr beanbag or walking around a lake
which was pretty beautiful but is there
like a room in the monastery that you go
to it was a number of rooms is there
when I say in the Dharma hall where
they've got sandalwood burning and a big
big buddha statue you know it's just a
rack full of different cushions and you
can choose like the cushion and based on
once so and with other people there
pretty much you know what the [ __ ] they
should speak to they should speak to
what's at voodoo events that we could
get up I feel it okay yeah buzzing VVIP
cushions yeah you jump cushion yeah
exactly I won't get my free cushion yeah
that's all of it all of the above
what else has been happening a lot of my
classes a lot podcasting podcasters and
rory sutherland which you enjoyed anyone
who has not listened to the episode with
rory sutherland go and check out now
maybe in the show chris getting
absolutely pipe so during the podcast
with Rory the British Gas man came round
to fix his boiler so you had a problem
and Rory's a little bit like can that
Brian Blessed from Blackadder sort of
gruff British manly he speaks like a and
everything's a bit [ __ ] Shae
and yeah the British gas guy came around
let me see I've cut bits out but I had
to Oh I injured the entirety of the
exchange and it's just hilarious
this British gas guy comes back after
he's set him away in West LA podcasting
I left this bit in sure if he comes back
into the room he's like I'm it it's no
no it's alright already you had three
weeks actually the top of the bun I must
give you I must give me 20 pounds the
focus and he hasn't preset funds in yet
and I didn't realize myself smart what
you're wearing right so listening it
just sounds like you've had the biggest
cream riley ever for so I was gonna ask
you did whether he tipped him cuz I just
heard that no no no no I insist
yeah I think he got he got 20 quid up
his wallet and gave it to him he the the
thing that I really liked about him is
the way swears very tactical yeah
because you know when sometimes people
use swearing as as filler the way he
swears really makes it sound better it's
necessary sentence yeah because you said
[ __ ] [ __ ] cap yeah brilliant it's
because it's very deliberate I think
yeah some people swear when they're
thinking of words or buying for talking
whereas this new designer Constance
we're all inter but it's idiosyncratic
as well for a lot of people whereas his
is very deliberate little precise speech
which i think is that precise speeches
one thing if you design a good podcast
guest all of the best podcasts i've done
with people who are precise with the
speech there's nothing more or less than
they need to say and they say exactly
what they need to hear I just think his
opinion on I feel such an affinity with
him because of his
in towards the shot tougher which is the
bum spray the high-pressure bombs
because he was like the world would you
get a bit of poo on your face and just
why though for the bit of dry paper it's
a disgrace barbaric they've got it right
haven't they yes I feel about this with
another bum spray yeah wet toilet paper
people think it's just for [ __ ]
pervert so he says that if we put those
pre wetted toilet papers rather than on
the top shelf of the supermarket where
it looks like the pervert shelf yeah if
you just put it somewhere that's really
accessible yeah then was there so
mainstream thing what I just it was
sentence use of like his job is just to
sit and think isn't it at the top of a
big monkeys at the top of a big
organization that he's just got a big
chair in a room sicko I just shares our
sales and thinks about like where might
the world be going so um if you go on
goggle V's website and it's not charity
no no yes I implore you to go on and
have a look and it says Rory Sutherland
vice chairman of Olga V advertising and
below that but I swear to god one of the
first couple of sentences is something
akin to Rory created his own job title
which is purposefully vague because
their advisor Chan yeah there will be it
but it must be on the board I'm gonna
presume as well but then this is like
Ogilvy UK yoga because David Ogilvy is
dead yeah so now it's these set up is
massive all over the world Michael
they're all over the world but yeah I
mean when he was some of the stuff he
said about like hey you know I do think
that the Russians are probably pretty
[ __ ] drivers on you know on balance but
that's because of everyone's every car
seems to come with him a camera in the
front of it so speaking of which that's
another so I've been rear-ended twice in
the last month in a car in a car
mechanic
yeah one was my fault one wasn't so the
guy who's was my fault
paid for the one who wasn't so on break
even but and if I see great experience
in credible experiences it's you know
what it is as soon as you feel that
impact the sense isn't it's not like I'm
gonna it is just all of the admin flux
such a that's way more painful than any
whiplash could could do cuz you like
there is certainly something afoot here
there's I think eyes come in clusters
like that well I'd love to know so I
have a theory that people with dash cams
getting more accidents and people who
ironically my - come I got a crap one
and it didn't record when it actually
needed to work so got rear-ended the
first time tried to take my dash cam out
plug into the computer and records like
30-second clips of journeys that I've
done five years ago
nothing nothing about the seminar and
because it was still at home I was
trying to get the footage from so I'm
just gonna get rid of it and buy a dual
facing one because you think they're
most hangers did you just have one
facing in one direction just a front
facing okay yeah so yeah you will facing
one that connects to you phone or Wi-Fi
is almost impossible really
yeah the redundant in the market someone
who has access to small portable video
cameras does it just record onto a hard
drive and then reset reset record on
deep yeah and then it has some of them
have a sensor so if you if it has an
impact it will save the last 10 minutes
I mean a lot of the life stuff like
canary is I think it's 28 days the
records on cloud even then after 28 days
it'll just I've been more Canaries so
insecure yeah like says nest or whatever
I whatever
speaking of which Darren got a nest I
think I've told you this before he got a
nest which is like a smart thermostat
house and because he's him and his wife
have got the young child and dogs and he
has a chaotic working environment like
there's no continue sorry is that I mean
vibrating phone doing a podcast is is
that is that what you're going to do is
it's like
turn it on silent that's on sir but it
vibrates yeah is that what happens at
night yeah that's disgusting
there's only good things I've told it
that's disgusting I don't like who
doesn't like mine being woken up by a
really good thing that is a story that I
don't know whether we've mentioned this
where I came to pick Johnny up at 7:00
a.m. for a competition we were going to
Leeds I think we have spoken but oh okay
come on corn I went to went to his
family home not in this door this was a
few years ago mom answered the door and
I was like have you seen Johnny I know
no not seen them I don't know where it
not just hear footsteps running down the
stairs Johnny's like oh like bleary-eyed
like what time is it is 7:25 Oh God he
was like right you know what's happened
my uncle watch at 4:00 a.m. woke me up
and just said beep-beep you've been sat
down to a long time to get up so I so I
got up in like what are you doing Johnny
[Music]
so he went back to sleep and then it
didn't wake him up well do you actually
need to do this is when we try and
optimize too hard like I so that there
was a good tweet that Jordan pile
yesterday there
George Bobby yesterday saying about
asymmetric risks and one of the biggest
things I hear it was yeah right
well it's about rather counter Voyageur
job got it but it wasn't neither was it
was Neville rather camp bot which is
owned by George if you are on Twitter
and check out its naval bot nav al BLT
and it's just like aphorisms they're
unbelievable on the loop one of the
biggest I think one of the biggest
asymmetrical risks is single alarm clock
it's dangerous yeah I had one day when
it fails yeah that's the days you can't
really need it yeah so bye so it's
asymmetric risks and asymmetric benefits
opportunity option so in other words the
size of the game is smaller than the
risk
yes eyes are the risk is smaller than
the position with the small stop-loss
and a very very large tech profits so
are the opportunities yes yes so this
the what's
there has a smaller size small upside
massive does so as if in texting while
driving
yeah is the sexting texting while
driving texting another person while
you're in a relationship is another one
like you get a very limited upside
benefit to that we're doing mostly taxes
with another yoson yeah was it you that
said like if you would if you have to
show the text that you were writing
while driving in court then uh yeah and
if I can I say you had a crush or you
killed someone you hit a pedestrian and
then in court they're like well what
text were you writing and you're like
mmm or like just so so [ __ ] vapid
[ __ ] yeah it is the trouble is when
you're next in the car watch how many
people come in the other way looking at
the road so few people yeah and you
think if they veer off what am I gonna
do
so with automated car it what's called
self-driving cars
apparently is like her it's like a
hundred or a thousand fold less risk to
die by a self-driving car than it is
didn't this is this is what people
prefer to be bit like they're scared of
self-driving cars because they prefer to
die by their own hand even if it's a
hundred me and you both quote to eat the
same thing that we refer to die by our
own volition than live at the behest of
a machine unbelievable
you're like I suppose it's when it's
when machine goes wrong it's the
destroying of planet to make Paperclip
scenario isn't it so the problem the
problem that people have with it is that
for some reason they're prepared with a
huge amount of real risk that comes from
humans a huge amount of human risk but
this tiny and then they obsess about
what wife it's a mother of three versus
a pram with a baby and you're like when
is that ever gonna have the footwell do
you make that position yeah okay so it's
a utilitarian somehow better to leave
that decision in the hands of human kill
them both
- oh gosh - shop and kill 10 people yeah
I just left has that just make it like a
judge valiant cost of life and just make
the best decision yeah you can do
everything - Elon Musk yeah I'll tell
you what else I've been listening to
recently the end of the world with josh
clark best times cheery link will be in
the shot up to the law it is the
most advanced and clever use of the
podcast platform that I've listened to
so far so if you can imagine a 10
episode podcast series where he is
talking about different existential
threats as asteroids AI risks physics
experiments all sorts everything very
very comprehensive and the entire show
has been engineered by very very clever
sound engineers and this soundscapes
going on in the background so as he's
talking about traveling through space
there's like whooshing space sounds and
kind of low-level music and rumbling
when he will talk about asteroids then
be great on three times speed I don't
listen to I do listen to audiobooks in
two times speed I listen to podcasts as
they are I think I see a podcast as
leisure leisure but an audiobook is like
I'm reading this for work to gain
occasion I do I see all audio as wasting
your time I consume it as rapidly here
to be honest three times pushes my limit
a bit but don't even get so the only way
that you can get three times speed is by
going at the specific kinds of apps so
if even if you zip hack scone if you're
listening now on Apple podcasts I
implore you to try this out if you press
the multiplication thing it will go
11.52 not point five so I really yeah
I'm using a new podcast app called
Castro which is excellent but it only
has like one 1.2 1.5 up to two and then
the next beat up is three and two is too
slow for me and three is a little bit
too fast but would you like an egg and
it metastasizes bone cancer explain that
it was just in Iceland you were
listening to some really kind of drawl
guy talk about all the different ways
that shin cancer becomes so I saw my
bedroom was the living room so I was on
the sofa and Youssef was very unwell the
entire time and I just could I'd wake up
DC mornings the first morning I woke up
to yourself standing wearing a woollen
half and some shorts cooking on a
portable hub in the corner of a room
that thing blew me away by the way we
got the portable of yeah it's yes it's
like a if you close a laptop and make it
twice as thick
that's a hob and it's a it's a holiday
how is it generating the heat
unbelievable but yeah so it's my these
positions slow slow Trucy stuffs like
crouched over this hole with a pan turns
around and says would you like an egg
single egg boiled egg that was one who's
off from here for my breakfast which had
declined I believe I think we only had
three left so is just gonna be yeah and
then we bought some Lucky Charms which
were the cheapest cereal in Iceland nine
thousand four hundred pounds this is a
person there's a discount yeah and I
don't have tried to get him to
supermarket then not in half grandfer
should we talk about fire festival yeah
and I've already talked about with other
contests but it's just so good it did
you watch this I mean it now yeah happy
yeah watch it at normal speed normal
speed you with on you and Ben's
recommendation did you watch it with Amy
yeah so I the only times I'm forced to
watch things at normal speed are if
those are the people you just got it
when you use will you say something that
doesn't fit into this is what Youssef
does you've got to find the the reason
wasn't justification well is it oh yeah
so one of my favourite to segue before
we go on the fire festival one of my
favorite things is way you say you can
have a five pound discount on massages
that you give people so you're a trained
myself or people a five pound discount
if they allow you to listen to whatever
podcast or audiobook you're listening to
at the time but obviously if you flip
that on its head what you could look at
is there is a 5 pound surcharge if you
don't want to listen to what
that's a good point five pounds is so
arbitrates like it's it's enough of it
you probably sitting is also similar say
yes because I remember Gipper saying he
was having a meal and it was okay I
suppose there's anything about straddle
options it's actually you should charge
people for that but it's like the stuff
you have access rate excellent
educational content for you a lot of its
paid like it's either part of a 9 grand
a year degree or a paid program that's a
good point actually like it is
value-added yeah but it's just very much
miss you recognize the value know if
you're on L send not if you're on Oh
same here um yeah and then to bookend
that conversation when you've finally
gotten to the life hack is getting a
haircut at home haven't you yeah ah
thank you
but before before the hairdresser went
round to his she texted me to say like
hang on a second I'm about to go around
to this person's house that I've never
met before I probably should think about
my own safety is he easy a weirdo and
I'm like the canary in the coal mine is
me like that's probably but and then
apparently so I knew that this was gonna
be I could foresee the scoby problem
occurring language with it is not a
touchy kind of no but tie you up weirdo
yes just it's what's people it's used to
make you feel uncomfortable
yeah so what I had in my head that I
knew it was gonna happen and sure enough
it did was that Yousef was gonna be sat
down and he would be forced to make
small talk with someone in his house but
he would know that at that point all
that you needed to do would be like
press the play but there's too many you
know like that as you're on ramp like
introduction use of 101 like you can't
have use of 101 as
I was like did he um did he make did he
play anything in that she's like no no I
was like [ __ ] no I did sit so I gave
her a 10-minute grace payment a small
talk and then I was like right I think
we've reached threshold is like I've
established that I am a know that I can
pretend to be normal in a few minute n
minutes hey I'm just listening to the
middle of a podcast can I and I was like
you know what I'll be nice I must put
the speed to an order I think I put on
like 1.2 and her she wouldn't know but
it was it was Stan Grof talking about
like the psychoanalytic map yeah
she spends all day hearing to people
hearing people talk about reveal
magazine very well to be fair is quite
yeah it was like the cartography of
archetypes of Jesus give me an
architectural yes
so fire fest so tell me what you think
because I'm absolutely [ __ ] amazed you
thought so for anyone that doesn't know
I suppose fire was a really impressively
it was it a festival it was a nap okay
so starting started off as a nap and
then they decided to launch a festival
off the back of it very good at hype
they hired a lot of supermodels and high
High Definition high production value
stuff took own film the promo for
festival hour in the Bahamas buying one
of pablo escobar's old islands and they
were going to host it down oh they said
yesterday they made it look like an
amazing experience got a lot of
high-profile people a bit weird
blink-182 and ja Rule I also like lapses
of 1996 that you would have looked at
that lineup and gone so they all fell
down when they actually went to
implement it and realize
Island had no infrastructure the
organization was a complete mess and
just seeing the whole thing
progressively fall apart the way that
the documentary is made is so
impressively stressful as well did you
find this where like you sat there in
your life
ah well my my empathy but as a business
person just had me that I was white
knuckling I was thinking it's all right
up your street because it's like yeah
well I mean head funny any of the Cupra
mothers there listening is just it's all
of our worst nightmares rolled into one
at what point could you tell that it was
gonna get over I realized that the
premise of the show pretty pretty soon I
think like as soon as they talked
because it's the stuff that you don't
think about the the infrastructure of
things like by a waste disposal like the
problem wasn't really fancy stuff
getting rid of poo where'd you put the
poo lemon island $100,000 worth of Evian
water the the awful director had to go
and suck off the customs officer and I
turned up there fully prepared to suck
his dick you're like he got loads of
positive we saw legend oh yeah do you
know what the other thing is as long as
it there's like a wake but so yeah I
mean I thought it was it was really
really I've watched it twice now that's
how much angel I felt very sorry for I
watch it again Billy my father no I feel
very sorry for that much it's that's
really hard good of him because
basically the customs officer held was a
hundred thousand meters a hundred
thousand dollars worth I think it was
like 143 articulated lorries whoa Kay's
a hundred one hundred and forty thousand
dollar customs charge and the guy said
that he was gonna go over because the
customs officer was gay and trying to
seduce him and understood that everyone
told him that this is what he had to do
is what he had to do yeah so he was like
commandeered it's like you're the
highest profile gay man that we've got
my field is evil it's so arrogant to
think like oh I like for me to give
someone a [ __ ] it's worth a hundred
and forty thousand dollars like I
suppose it's just what you've got at
that point isn't it
like it's either that or what would you
have to if it was the other way around
who would pay that much I don't think
anyone's ever paid $140,000 in Canary
it's good
let me we'll have done your absolutely
140 grand why not cuz you just find
someone that we've been into 839 how's
he paid it all right if you absorb that
if you absorb that as their as the
vendor you'd be like for a hundred and
forty grand [ __ ] ready to business
you could claim that back on the
transaction yeah you know I don't good
what's that what's the what's the input
but there is not tonight man
if there's an absolute right it's
[ __ ] perilous has been here in for a
[ __ ] but yeah I mean one of them one
of the main things I said this to Alex
on the on the podcast was that the big
difference and this shows how seduced we
are by success the only reason that
everyone slates that but the guy that
ran it and the festival itself is
because it failed mm-hmm and if the
stars have aligned sufficiently
correctly and a bunch of very lucky
things the water had got sorted in the
tents it got side and it wasn't that
weekend where all of the yachts were
there and linens yeah and it hadn't
rained and miss another bunch of things
basically his preparation and skill
level and virtue in integrity hadn't
moved at all on the meter but all of the
look was turned up to 11 and it all
worked fine if it was real fraudulently
gaining oh yeah stuff but things have
been successful we'd be hailing him as
the [ __ ] here and it's purely because
we are so seduced by success we want to
be attached to success so much that is
by any means possible so I think it's I
think he's pretty smart bloke so that's
not six years in jail now is it yeah
yeah obviously yes that part's not smart
but like I think the like I there are
not very many people you could get
something to that point did you trust
him do you think he was a charismatic
guy no I don't know you don't trust him
mother
yes I thought across at all those
seemed yeah he's got something weird
about even as like he's got a strange
gait when he walks tsunami and yeah he's
obviously got some sociopathic kind of
like detachment tendencies because his
facial expression looked as if and they
were engineered I do you know what I
mean that is if he'd like thought how
can I like it wasn't matter it was meta
cognizant for the entire time that he
was you do not mean like he was thinking
like what would Billy McFarlane say in
this in this moment yeah and apparently
there's a hulu version which I'm yet to
watch there's a same thing but different
documentary and the hula version focuses
a lot more on him right which it I'm
looking forward to watching
apparently in that there's a bit some
footage for money's in court is this
[ __ ] crazy American system where you
can just like take a camera in a court
but yeah that's what's going on and yeah
apparently does this bit where they say
basically did you say this he says no
and they say his video of you saying
that you did say it and you can see
apparently that cut like he's there's
like a cognizant just yeah where he's
like super hang on a second like I did
but I didn't but I did but it like no I
am it's obvious that he's just got he's
a compulsive liar yeah who is unable to
reconcile a number of different things
that these if you look at what he I know
he didn't deliver on the on the product
but the rap was very good someone's made
a [ __ ] documentary about him yeah but
and so you think like everyone's very
quickly criticized and I completely
understand that but the fact is you made
a made a big wave however now you need
to just put him in the marketing
department and have him just very good
enough yeah I mean I don't let me the
ops and I don't let him [ __ ] order
their climbing but even stuff like
getting everyone to post an orange tile
yeah I thought it's a very good idea I
just keep him like cordoned off yeah sit
in a room safe very whiteboard Nicky
Nicky stay in there mate and a camera
you can just do it yeah yeah so do you
think he was delusional or deceptive
combination because the I don't think
that you can have that degree I don't
think there's any amount of deception
which would allow you to continue
something when it's obvious it's not was
the one thing going wrong and he was
like guys
can't think about that we could be part
of solutions based business that I
promise based Pacific it's not just like
blind faith in his own ability and
thinking no no we've got to be positive
about this like because there's Tony
Robbins this up as hard as we can
or is it like he knows that it's going
wrong but like just doesn't what is
holding it's probably switched so I
imagine you didn't start off thinking
let's make this big scam I'm actually
started off thinking this is gonna work
and look you know when that guy like
prices it all up and says make this is
like 30 million quid overages yeah and
with you've got six weeks to do it in
it's normally done in six months yeah
that twelve it's like I think this earth
really yeah at that point it's like
[ __ ] how I got either [ __ ] off the
pot here like I better just go balls in
with this yeah and just hope it would I
think the thing that was most impressive
for me was where they were saying so
we'd run out of money and then Billy
would jump on a jet go back to New York
but then he'd come back with another
three million dollars bucket and you'd
be like Billy what the [ __ ] he's he's
sucking he's sucking like whatever
thirty thirty [ __ ] that's what you say
do you think that's what he was doing 30
times 140 minus handling fever I see I
see
Knut so right I think that's really what
he was doing no but but he was just
lying about his finances was need to get
there get the funding do you see that he
said he analogy held a number of
Facebook options and he had like 10
grand oh yeah I remember that like yeah
cuz his previous business was like he
sold it for a really small yeah small
amount but it almost felt to me like a
somewhat someone with a gambling problem
yeah like he loves the thrill of it and
doesn't want that the idea that some
costs I our largest I'll just tell that
line I'll just lie as well and it'll all
work out in the end somehow like what
the one turn the wheel I'll eventually
planning to save needs to read some
Harris so you need to do what's that
called where you the the Chinese thing
where they they make you take
incremental commitments that are
slightly on off your moral radar but
because they're so small you keep taking
larger and larger ones until you just
deep down the hole and you sound like
Darren brown don't round off
well yesterday shirts and every I think
there are and probably leverages that
it's a process very much it's the it's
the reverse of compounding interest
isn't it it's like a number of small
compounding bad decisions and before you
know it you like strung up by your
nipples and Rosie just seemed fine
because it was only one extra decision
here for it one each time yeah have you
seen the Ted Bundy tapes yet no have you
seen it Yusef seen something that use
are I mean I started watching it but I
I'm pretty [ __ ] story is it good
yeah I thought was pretty good right
yeah exciting it's just is just a very
charismatic good-looking guy that
happens to be a systemic public a
systemically naughty although that there
is still a divide between I think the
person that he thinks he is and wants to
try and be very much like the Billy
thing actually is quite quite scary has
a lot for how that's what that's what I
meant
there's another one that James Bailey
recommended me to watch yeah which I've
seen called abducted in plain sight so
I've watched that you should watch that
is Maddie McConnell no similar no oh my
god like why give us a synopsis so that
the three shows that you've mentioned
doesn't easily the and it gave us the
best circle I would love man I stood up
to get a drink right I'm walking walking
to the fridge and someone says something
I turned round and one yeah I can't
believe it should we spoil it for for
the audience I know I don't spoil it
don't spoil it
well there's a scene where a guy there's
two men in a car
yep hey do you know the poem about I
said yeah but I feel like the
Orientalist is the most like like what
led to that point is makes it seem even
more ridiculous okay
I'm not I'm saying okay well so
basically it's a family three daughters
they made friends with another family
the husband of the other family
developed a develop a friendship and
he'd about the particular proclivity for
one of the daughters John he would the
parents were aware of it in there were
like oh yeah kind of angered us but we
thought you know whatever carried on and
then he would end up staying
at their house multiple times staying in
John's bed one day the father was away
wasn't able to take John to horse-riding
class he said I'll do it
drugged her took her away abducted her
for several days the parents didn't call
the police or the FBI until five days
later because they will are maybe
they're just I was riding or something
and that's the tip of the iceberg tip of
the octave of the iceberg and and so
then and prior to that as well what
turned out was that the man had made
sexual advances towards the wife of the
other family and so they had little
secret though so she felt hesitant to
actually go to the authorities about and
then later the husband and this other
guy had gone on a camping trip and
husband was like and we were sat in the
van and he looked over at me and he had
an erection he was like man I just need
some relief would he help me out he
helped brother out and I was like so I I
performed an act of masturbation and I'm
just like and you're like like tough sex
with both of the parents from the airing
and abduct the child
well then tried to Mario eventually he
manages to return the child back to the
house with the receipt they they don't
speak to him for a few weeks and then he
becomes mates with him again stays back
at a house over and it abduct her a
second time and when he's updated her a
second time the parents then know that
this happened and they know that he's
had previous convictions of being a
child abductor but he said to them are
don't worry I'm recovered now but part
of my therapy is to stay in the bed of
little girls and the parents of the
heart sounds legit ok and that's they
let him stay in the bed there's a it
works like he was sleeping in their room
5 nights of every 7 in her bed in her
hair about months right but it's a very
similar thing where the parents
completely deranged well no again this
is one of these questions with are they
delusional of a complicity again it
starts off with I just wanted to take a
horse riding once and then very quickly
becomes this mess of just it makes you
so much really parents yeah yeah it's
just like completely like it's a great
thing you're watching these things
I've just really steamrolled into
watching but it's it's a third I feel
like regular TV is brain-dead pointless
but stuff like this is really
interesting it's soothing it must be it
must be as palatable as you can make
television yeah it is it's it just is
quite a complex plot there's quite a lot
of information big mixture of emotion
yeah yeah because the thing is as well
that no one ever has this conversation
about Coronation Street yeah the
complexities of the meta cognition of
Roy Crocker if you like no no because
it's all just Ken canzoni enough there
would be no Coronation Street plot that
even came close to the ridiculousness
and that's real yeah and this actually
happened that's true you couldn't make
this stuff up you couldn't what are we
making murder at Liam Neeson enemies
I saw one thing of it and then I was
like something yeah if you start with
that you persevere it's a very similar
thing where it gets Dianna Yannick I
can't believe this is Harvey what's the
second season no second seasons not as
good but just like the first season spun
20 years right very much of timeline
yeah the second one spun since then
until now so alright they're gonna have
my stretches but they've got there's a
lady lawyer who is representing him
right if I hear she was promoted [ __ ]
yeah an absolute like in Proverbs
wheeling the big minigun and just yeah
when the noise is so uniform it's yeah
yeah
the there's another one called the
staircase scene that no it's about a guy
who gets the guys in the house with his
wife and his wife dies by falling down
the stairs and the police arrive but
there's like blood all down the stairs
like smeared everywhere he's like she's
just fell down the stairs in the UK no
it's in the US and he's a famous author
fiction no cook it's a bits proper like
police tape stuff and people like and we
came to the house and she's in a right
mess like jumping out everywhere like
like all of the war everything is like
she's just merciful know this and it
that's careers will be this camera
footage that vindicate so where she just
absolutely reminds me of this video it
went viral a few years ago of this guy
who breaks up with his wife do you know
about this where he he creates like a
trail oh [ __ ]
yes have you seen this he's it's the
it's really savage I'll try and find it
link in the show notes below yeah it's
like a incremental set of videos this
guy founds out his wife's been cheating
then leads her on this like Valentine's
Day cigar enjoy think through the house
to the bed and the beds covered in roses
and it's the end of it there's like a
card and that's shaped like a heart and
just to go round find the different
things and there's a clue written on
each thing she's a chocolate and she
gets up to the bed and this like we will
this is the final stage of our little
trail we will then spend the next the
next time at northern lights in the hail
I finally have one more question for you
when I get one on down on one knee and
ask you who the [ __ ] is Thomas rude so
you lace it and locks the door puts the
key through the door he's like that's
just proof so that the police know that
I haven't got a key anymore and he
drives off into the night singing into
her dildo and like the whole time
there's a lot of like excitement in his
voice but you can hear the tone of
sadness underneath one is just like you
that's the way to deal with it though
and I kid this British as well isn't
like a guy it's like from yeah it's like
just Yorkshire or leads or something
like that and the guard sorry used me
it's very realistic and it's all filmed
in like 916 vertical right like a
front-facing camera for my darlin glue
number four and then okay over to the
next one like sparkles and glitter on
the phone I have like a psychotic event
when he's found out about it he said
masterminded this real just accessed
another level of cognition because he's
been so hurt by I think you driving off
with her dildos like it's the final
level of thought yeah that's and
realization isn't it
actualization that's self actualization
like for Dylan I mean that muscles
hierarchy of needs and then at the very
very top it's just not the top is the
tip of the dildo tip of the dildo
that's Liam Neeson we're gonna talk
about the amazing this is a [ __ ]
minefield for us to say can we get some
background on also for the people who
don't know Liam Neeson lorries are
taking a set of skills
guess he doesn't why he doesn't that's
the issue Liam Neeson no that's the
first sound video games ever made but
he's not in the room so Liam Neeson is
promoting a new film which I think it's
actually a dark comedy I don't think
it's actually an action film it's a dark
comedy about revenge and during an
interview he is asked how do you
understand the emotions that are going
through this and in his very sort of
dark slow
gravelly kind of way Irish voice he says
well I have a personal experience with
this a close friend of mine was raped
and I asked her did she know the person
and she said no and I said why ethnicity
was she and she said it was a black man
so for the next few nights I went out
with a cosh which is like a small baton
walking the streets of Island in black
neighborhoods looking for a black man to
start on me so that could kill him and
after a little bit of time I thought
caught myself and a lot of the emotions
had drained a little and I was able to
be shocked at my own degree of behavior
nothing had occurred but that's how I'm
able to embody or understand this
particular degree of revenge he only
talks about the shame that he felt on
himself and said I realized that even
this was me feeling this in the context
of living in Northern Ireland and seeing
all of the the atrocities of the that
had done and yet still having fallen
prey to that same thought loop and then
realizing that actually I'm just as bad
as them and and then yeah so I guess he
said he had that thought forty years ago
was it yeah and so people were slating
him now
they called him a racist for having a
thought forty years ago and that he's
recognized he acted on it and did I've
done it yeah well yeah I suppose it's
supposed to no consequence similar
suppose II said about the fire thing
where like nothing was nothing happened
yeah I mean so the thing that's it's a
DC John BIRT John Barnes the foil or
stuck up for him it has come out saying
it's a hero and you like yeah I mean
fair enough Joe bonds not the first
person I think of to call on a very very
peculiar guys yeah you know where's that
connection do you know if Liam needed to
call on someone of like black heritage
you wouldn't be like you know Denzel I
bet you ain't done so very similar guys
only yeah I don't like equalize the dose
or mode Ainsley Harriott what gravitas
does Ainsley Harriott bring to the
conversation or the mean why you think
it's not in see her eat the ticket
outlets Travel Lodge is it's a smidge
racist well know that the two similar
aged British black like TV personalities
[Laughter]
I think it's actually because Lenny
Henry hasn't routine where he was
approached by certain media company
saying can you do this cake for us and I
slowly transpired
he was that's true yeah so I think it's
one of the routines that one of them has
anyway
okay so um have you seen all of the NZ
Harriet videos where these people have
had really taken it seriously
they've gone full video caighdeán on it
and this is energetic quite scary
they put my scene horror music over the
top and that looks like easy Harry on
the top of it the top of a cliff
goodness and then he's like whisking
this thing for ages
and then he's rubbing meat and Yoko wrap
and there's a whole like it's very
harrowing ziran on YouTube of this stuff
Jesus it'll be on reddit or fortune it
won't matter for honestly love honey
internet does that it just rolls but
something's just yeah we and they'll
have no idea why yeah so yet Liam Neeson
and then John Barnes and this there's
been a he's been the subject of an awful
lot of derision for us and laws which is
mad because you are right like it was 40
years ago it was something then the main
question is can someone be held
accountable for thoughts that they have
because you are right that's essentially
all that happened and the argument is
well if it had been Irish Manor if it
had been a Swiss person or a German or a
Eurasian or whatever it is the the
racism wasn't racism it wasn't racism
against people of black heritage it was
tribalism against anyone from the tribe
of people who are I guess later as well
then he said I was just looking for a
symbol of my anger that I could it was
an avatar right he was looking for
someone to outlet that aggression onto
and some Harrison Joe a Joe Rogan said
like hit the nail on the head and they
were like if you want people in the
world to be able to learn from others
mistakes like that situation you're not
going to get much more perfect than this
is a learning opportunity for everybody
to understand someone who has everything
to lose
talking about a situation like this so
Liam Neeson with all of his qualities
and virtues that everyone admires him
for being this amazing actor and looking
so cool and he's he's everyone's perfect
uncle
and you're like and this guy has had the
bravery to come out and even he as
talented and famous as he is is still
falls prey to these kind of juvenile
like I suppose its final should he not
have thought it or should he not have
said that he thought it because there
was unity things that have happened and
people are criticizing him so I'm sure
most people have had a dark thought at
some point and so the lesson is here
that you're not allowed that if you have
a dark thought like that
you can't tell never talk about to hear
is it as if that's the solution I've
only got the key got the cost show and
he walked out with it much more than a
dark thought isn't it that's what
everyone's good ok ok so suppose it's
that's an action of someone being a very
emotional very very upset very angry
taking a step towards acting on
something but caught himself before he
did it but it's still better than acting
on it definitely yeah so there it is a
difficult one though you know there are
people especially the the thought police
kind of people that try and jump on
things like this they are under this
illusion or lie that they don't have
prejudices as if as if there's somehow
these like beacons of it's like everyone
has prejudice is that the data shows
that like so fat people is a particular
example that the data shows that people
who look at photos of fat people on
average will rate them as less
intelligent and less charismatic or less
likeable and the certain quality is that
or lazy yeah they say is you smelly all
those sorts of things like divisions
associated with lack disciplining down
there and what that feeds into and so
the you know there's there would be
similar ones with with all kinds of
minorities or groups of people but with
any characteristic yeah any quite
interesting someone who's long earlier
someone who's tall someone who's sure
actually if you have to be able to
discriminate to be able to navigate your
way in the world so it's not as if if
you just eliminate all of that people
are blind to color around blind where
it's like that's not you're not very
effective from if it's effective an
actor there are you
yeah it's it's just not possible like
you you know this is it's the same about
people who I remember the reason I
watched the fire documentary was my like
Instagram social media like lights up
with everyone's got an opinion on why he
was [ __ ] but like you don't know he it's
easy to just look at him look at a car
he was like tried to make something
fantastic and it's gone down the [ __ ]
and you really made a mess of it in lots
of ways but like at one point it started
off as a great idea and a brilliantly
executed idea that might have been
fantastic and no one knows how they
would have reacted in his situation when
they were faced with this like [ __ ]
hell I got taken this too far
it's very various from the armchair and
Bjork I'll actually was most people
couldn't even get anything at that point
I've never seen another scene from the
fire festival documentaries come in my
head which is ja Rule sat on that Google
hangout with everyone like [ __ ] out
guys like you know don't need to worry
yeah like like nobody died any like okay
like yes you're right nobody died and
what's the example that uses remember
what you might thinking like it could
have been quite likely people who could
have died on yeah this is an example
with like some company that came back
from them
oh yeah from the brink and it was like
like look they date Hammacher know that
was one of the examples that was used
that was used by the other guy was it
but it's like you know like oh is
Samsung so I got a Samsung are there
throw your phones in people's pockets
like you know we're not killing anyone
you like you right yeah maybe you're not
[ __ ] some somehow it's right they
have quite a lot of reputation before
yeah well they didn't open up with a
brand new phone that blew people's likes
off okay have you seen as well you will
have done cos you got on flight to all
the time to weddings done you constantly
and have you seen now that if you drop
your phone in between the seats of a
plane you're not supposed to move your
seat I'll try and get the phone yourself
you need to be and wait for the
monotonicity co why because their
concern is if you have like a Samsung
Galaxy Note 7 or whatever the [ __ ] in
this state and you move you move your
seat back crack it
all right and the lithium battery goes
that everyone's up in force this is why
you shouldn't be allowed on plane unless
you've got an iPhone
and everything would be much simpler
because the people who've made bad
decisions will be confined to the where
they live that is true we're gonna get a
lot of hate for that Rory Rory
Sutherland says the same he's like you
know after a while people don't care
about clock speed or megapixels for the
for the front-facing camera after a
while they just want something that
looks nice you're like what that's it
that's exactly why so the fact that you
have an iPhone and you have a MacBook is
is that is the explanation of why it's a
bender so if you are canary in the
coalmine for you you shop on features
you don't care about the fact like
downloads this though this is like if we
might an old life or if you look like
the the Google pixel or like whatever
layer Samsung is probably on a features
per per pound basis is much not that's
not my criteria though your those
integration would existing yeah it's a
convenience integration and speed of
access for stuff that's why after it is
the closest thing to my heart that
anything ever could where's your hat for
the webinar um let me George got me a
lovely Christmas present which is a cap
that says make Alfred great again yes
they don't even have an affiliate scheme
I offered what are you doing yeah do you
know that if 95 to 98% of people they
were listening won't know what Alfred is
and I thinking this is Morgan Alfred
fellows good isn't it sounds like a nice
mix laugh yeah he's a pretty good fella
I tell you what if Liam Neeson had
Alfred oh he wouldn't had these problems
he wouldn't have to know
so why do you have why do you buy a map
book rather than a PC because you didn't
buy a Casey thought out Alfred exists
yeah I didn't but I think use it but
anyone use a PC for three minutes and
it'll aren't so many people like because
it where are you to work everyone has
pcs so this is a manager as well yes was
just what the system's run on so we both
worked in companies where you're forced
to use user base and at their time you
just
you see this one uses a PC they think
Mac's like I can't use it there's no my
computer there's no you know no control
panel water I tell you that not
onboarding process to learn to use a Mac
is about thirty minutes isn't it
like I think that's such a weak excuse
to say that it is like using the only
comparison that I can make between
having a MacBook and having anything
else is actually no I
I've never used Linux or no I like those
is Linux but I see that as like like
stabilizers off like really good if you
can make it work or use it's not so ABC
listed so it used I think about ten
years ago maybe 15 years ago if you had
a bit of developing knowledge you could
really use Linux to your advantage and
arisen in the forefront now Mac has even
overtaken that and there are a lot of
developers moving over to using Mac as a
as a thing and the problem with PC is
that because it's incumbent because
large banks and lot you know lots of
there's lots of corporate use of
Microsoft even though it's terrible and
even though there's so much problems
with it because of the cost of such a
switch everything over is so large I
don't know I've never ever walked into
Santander or like Lloyd's and looked
behind ago everyone's got really imacros
yeah it's not entirely if some that'll
be cost processing crazy it's just so
ironic because like if they had up all I
mean how let's say if you were to add up
all the time that you spend waiting for
a computer at your old job like per day
well I'm not the amount of times that to
repair my computer okay so it's at the
number of work hours that they're like
total labor that's lost must pop all the
employees of the company it's got to go
into the fiber on a MacBook Pro it's
just really it's like using a different
machine it's a different category of
everything mmm-hmm okay yeah if you ever
played in a phone shop with a different
phone
there isn't an iPhone not a long time I
just feel like I don't know obviously
I'm biased but I feel like using it is
more cumbersome in every way
I I would honestly love if if anyone's
watching this on youtube and you have a
sincere objection to or some reason that
we're overlooking it's like why should
we use a physical pigs or why'd you use
a Samsung Galaxy Note 7 or ecology of
all he is like I'd be keen to switch if
there's some cause if it's something
most most of the people that have said
to me you should switch that it's on
it's on either on price or because they
don't like Apple mm-hmm so like the
reason my reason not buying a Samsung is
not because I don't like Samsung that's
because I like Apple and what I will
make and everything just obviously
whether I want to like salsa I want to
like a PC they're just a contrarian with
it well if it's much better than than
great yeah it's so you're right like by
if you handle them by Samsung laptop to
get the same connectivity you would have
a worse experience than what you have
now the downstream effects of changing
that device ah airports don't work I or
they really have got us locked in iPad
won't sync up like laptops not good
things like if we all went to a cafe and
I have a lot the password for the Wi-Fi
and you two didn't press a button and
you both got the password yeah you know
a lot of things like that so in Sandton
thought what someone's life like with a
MacBook and then let's make it a little
bit easier yeah and that's what they do
it's either faster exchange David's life
he was storage Lee one of these like ah
really well I'm not paying 300 quid for
a laptop which is a secondhand
refurbished up all my [ __ ] deal yes
and I was like look just bite the bullet
do I have to bully him into buying one
he eventually did and now after a couple
of weeks of his ego kind of said he's
been like you know what Youssef yeah cuz
he's got Alfred no I have to take him
self studies he's a big technophobia
right but he's like why didn't I do this
earlier this is such this made my droid
iPhone we had used to have a Chromebook
I think you saw it yeah it was like a
party was held by two little threads and
all the plastic was peeled off and he
had to like hold it like that and hold
the plug in socket as well otherwise it
would flicker off and you could only
work if you held it at a certain angle
I was like David you've really run that
into the ground like do not feel guilty
about treating yourself to a new device
at this stage unbelievable
but yeah Liam Neeson knew new airports
coming out in my house you know that we
are you said I googled this yesterday
yeah
did you know what it was you are going
is it not true no no I lied I saw a I
saw some related video for something and
it said best knockoff airports $50 right
there was a guy reviewing these knockoff
airports and then the thing after that I
said airports too so I looked up
airports too and yeah they seem to do
like a matte black version it's gonna
come out next month with some of the
features
it just doesn't excite me at all I like
my bean pods are lovely I think they I
think the features are wireless charging
and hey Siri being a comedy that's not
part of the you can just DoubleTap it
yeah you don't DoubleTap to activate
okay I've got a theory on that book now
did you know what before notice I had to
remove it it's a special setup you have
to do to enable hey Siri Oh what would
it just picks up yeah we'll go over nine
life hacks 107 wow really cool I'm just
having a look here so it's saying the
potential release date will be within
the next couple of months latest news
iPods - if this is true it's oh [ __ ]
airports - will reportedly support a
grippier new coating to make the plastic
less prone to slipping out of your hands
and ears
another feature improved base although
the design is expected remain the same
another thing which could be quite cool
would be the github biometric sensors in
them so you be I was rocking fitness
tracking from the ears so their work
wait for the people who are listening
Yusuf's making a rude gesture with his
crotch what's your stretching my on
rocking up steps yeah we're gonna do
we're gonna do a life hacks episode so
although no no about that apparently if
you have an apple
and these new airports the Apple watch
can measure your heart rate but the
airports can measure to an know like
volume like pulse volume or something
what you mean the volume I don't know
Jimmy I love you no no no it to do with
like the how does it help me out 100 see
what this is your place so the this
because I know that Apple watch has an
ECG yeah so something to do with because
it can feel your blood flowing
my blood pressure picks up something
else I don't know it was in a losing a
TechCrunch article I read the bottom
line is that you need to buy a pair of
air pods and not change your life who
doesn't in the model was a group of them
just him
did George and Jordan both get them yep
off the back of life hacks 101 I just I
don't think I've got anything else the
trouble is now is that it's got to the
point where it's better though isn't it
you to get them they'd have to be so
good we've heard enough we've origin it
arose immediately and there were like
these are quite good you know wonder
like yells not like these dentist in my
ear properly the sounds a bit rubbish
like you've got to charge them
separately I just and they look like
you're wearing a tampon in your ear the
whole thing the whole package just
doesn't do it I you what you're not
doing is is justifying yeah let's talk
yeah I can see why you'd think that
[Laughter]
cuz also if we thought you said that
would I think make it worse i I would
honestly be annoyed at you if you
because I know my birthday's coming up
you probably like considered it and I
will be very annoyed I'm just saying is
the old guys do well they do give me
like I'll be actively upset you just
like to like their pods and they told
you audible huh their pods are listening
Hammond of her home I did it was all
right babe so there's a pump the pump
the harm you said you really liked Parma
ham yeah yeah so nice a bit should pick
up the shoe hospital
engine birthday Oh God she was
incredible like works as a weapon as
well
Dean has won hum was okay mixed bag a
lab it was apartment on but people have
said to me afterwards I you shouldn't
have just eaten on its own you have to
like it was like a baguette or something
yeah it's like someone buying me like a
rotisserie chicken and you just think it
cold out of pocket yeah I see oh right
okay I'm sorry cuz we were late to go to
coop we have to go back to a nice house
you could put the pom-pom in the fridge
[Music]
yeah and this time thinking you have to
go back to charge ear pods external
charger other um before we go what have
we got coming up what episodes are we
gonna do coming up so we're gonna do or
this may come out after life hacks 107
so either in the past or the future of
podcast we may have done or will be
doing yes
life hacks 107 yeah what it's really
like running a business
yeah how to survive after university
after we had that one request yeah the
trouble with that is we've got to go up
to death home we survive because it's
everything after university so bear
attacks
yeah Holocaust farming the first thing I
thought I mean the trouble is I don't
get attacked by pear if you're at
universities there a bear free zone
because the triggers particularly they
open the gates and you should massive
fields and it goes on for miles and
there's bears and battles and if you're
not fast roaring if he's not seeing it
like when you open the gates from
university it's just a bunch of like
sullen bears you know I kind of just
kicking the heels on the floor smoke
smoking wearing leather jacket with one
foot against the wall alright leaning by
I just can't believe how fast their room
Bears terrifying if they were first yeah
but like proper clumpy runs faster than
you I could run [ __ ] yeah I think you're
trouble with seeing it by a bit a bear
that has decided I was talking Kim is
there's nothing today I've seen the
survival class but they say you need to
like put your hands over your head make
yourself as various puzzles but like I
would still not back myself to try that
thing like I really hope whoever wrote
this isn't just partner laugh because
otherwise like
your daddy's like oh you are so dead
definitely a bow at the top told you /
yeah oh I want a bit of a buzz yeah yeah
he's on the market you got a backi buzz
when leather wearing a sleeveless
leather jacket yeah yeah you know say
bet on each of them piss and hate that
was one of the Goodyear others wasn't it
like a bear with a bare with an axe or a
shot for the shotgun sure wasn't there
with an axe it's a bear doesn't have
opposable thumbs and a shark doesn't
have hands and it's underwater chuckles
you like where's the shotguns each
mounted here sorry I shot the shark us
to go back harness lemon juice
physically a shark does have a neck
either so just does that well you could
argue that any shark is all nice it's
just a fire charge to admit you've had a
shot because if possible it was a
terrifying thing I honestly can't think
of anything worse than the Python for me
dick squid for me really like that the
giant he's a big tube of muscle
they swim 30 miles an hour 110 foot long
if people could punch it as hard as he
could and it wouldn't you just have the
bucking bronco like grab it hug it and
just hold on I tell you what I tell you
what you should follow on Twitter which
is definitely worthwhile is extinct and
animals and rare animals right if you
search that they're both quite big quite
big Twitter accounts and they've just
put up like all of this mad megafauna
[ __ ] from 5 million 50 million years ago
it's like here is a extinct giant
chipmunk that grew to be 8 feet high and
had like Jesus like those things that
had six eyes things that had like horns
coming out there right now well because
it's boring there was like there was a
number of large extinctions and they're
mammals one where I want to see Brian
Cox Sheila I can't [ __ ] believe that
you articles the apps it's absolutely
blow your dick off just space-time just
being having someone explaining and
using a graph and maths space-time
you know he was saying on Joe Rogan that
they've basically for this show they're
just filling the entire back of stadiums
with LED screen yes and they have I
think it's like a hundred and something
square meters of LED paneling and that's
expensive per show they just fit it so
at Metro Radio Arena might be like 60
but then the plane like Wembley and it's
like 90 and then they're playing we're
at American it's like oh we can only get
50 but they just go in and apparently
the engineers are just like very is very
cinematic so as he's speaking these like
so they've got the so interstellar the
way they create black hole into servers
with an algorithm that morphs the
backdrop so they eat their two-star
backdrops of black black sky stuff in
stars run this algorithm and it creates
a black hole using what we understand
the science Otis it's a simulation not a
rendering yeah because there's like an
animation or simulation so they plug in
the universal constants this so it's in
hit crates yes
so he's accurate what you see exactly
though he appears yeah kidness me it
just thinks everything's gonna be
absorbed ultimately black holes
I've always sat down for this being like
yeah talk about being attacked by a bear
space-time fire festival any probations
come to the end of this knee like how do
you title it yeah I don't know if you've
got any ideas what we should call this
series we were gonna call it catching up
or just like so another example it's
just by a pair of [ __ ] and that's how
you should be called before I get so
aggressively bullied into if we have
everyone sends as a quid we'll buy some
air points easily easily after but
they're not look was an admin hustle
sneaks left to go and find everyone who
donated a quid returned it to them and
just some sell a pair of air pods and
then so what you're gonna do gonna pay
for the air pods using one pound
donations well I sell the molecule
crowdsourcing it and then you get the
airport after then return the airport
and find everyone's I see the back
anyway
what else we got coming up so I got the
house [ __ ] oh yeah
a selfie that screenshot of that girl
who is teaching your threes to do power
poses a superhero pose so we did an
episode on confidence it's when you were
away
you were already something I did the
confidence one you did confidence we
didn't do well maybe you did I cut it
wasn't anyway yeah I'm always how I get
lean and in that I cited a erroneous
study about power poses and now it's
been trickled down some year three easy
affecting kids lives Chris add genuine
young I'm really sorry but is a review
apologizing there is a primary school
teacher that's making kids do that and
they call it their superhero pose and I
said that's really cool
would you be able to send me a photo she
said yes but now she's had to check with
each of the parents individually is he
of course they're not miss possible huge
amount of downstream I'm alike message
to be the day like you don't need to do
it I don't really mind no no no no to be
honest it'll probably get receive a
benefit from it hmm yeah if they think
it's doing something the most it's the
most reliable affected all pharmacology
isn't it's like when you ask you like
your pakistani grandma asks you like
some food and you're like [ __ ] she's
gone she's away not I don't worry about
it I would just like coconut biryani and
chicken I know
you know how if you take a drug there's
a there's an effect of the drug like an
intended effect and then usually a side
effect that may we may either understand
or not understand yeah yeah is that the
case with with the placebo effect
can you get side effects progressing
like is it if it is placebo anything
that can be measured and if so is there
a side effect oh I see yeah so you can
influence neurotransmitters and but it's
the crazy thing about for SIBO is like
you can actually produce almost any sign
like in pretty skin signs and like if
you give someone what they think is an
allergen they might start getting like a
rash or so well yeah unbelievable yeah
and there would be no side effect if I
because it's just your body reacting
home I suppose you could get the side
effects that someone expects to get so
the amazing thing is like the
expectation and the power of the mind on
all of the human systems is it's so
weird cuz it annoyingly it's like you
have so much control over your body but
you don't have that control it's like
it's just by you isn't it but it's like
the which is why the preamble to so much
of this stuff is so important like if
you sell someone and this again is
obviously why even if you know so if you
write on a on a thing like memory pills
and you know that it's sugar and you're
taking it even though you're the one
that put the sugar pills in the thing it
still has an effect so placebo doesn't
get negated by knowing that it's placebo
so then if Musca it must be it's a used
in the regulated so if you know if i so
back in when i was seventeen and took
tribulus then you saying that because i
thought mrs. working this is gonna be
the that there might have been some
change or is it not are we not getting
hormone level no real like good deal
yeah so actually knowing that it doesn't
work is the worst thing that can happen
to ignorant is bliss i suppose also like
taking it at a tribulus a bit 17 like
you promised rose yeah we have all of
the the signs of high testosterone
anyway so you did didn't you
jacked
just swell jacked 17 I mean I feel like
I had quite a high testosterone
assembler dick to Knutson jacked yeah
so another thing did you see that the
house survived University I sent me this
screenshot got shared around a bunch of
schools in Papua New Guinea it's the
internet man so there was there was a
guy that contacted me and said that I
don't know whether it's expats with kids
out there or whether it's popping New
Guinean is that coming over to
university in the UK but it basically
said like we've got a lot of students
the 1617 are gonna go university over
the next year I've made them all watch
how to survive University well because I
think it's fate all of the stuff that
they meet to know [ __ ] oh that makes me
think like what did I say there's level
of responsibilities so much higher when
you realize that people actually listen
it's annoying when it's only post hoc my
arms look it was quite a good episode we
should just get like a big like big
warning screen at the beginning like the
following is Justin and you're not
medical advice at least he'd like legal
medical he's the doctor you are this bit
the following is not medical so I'm
gonna have to start qualifying I am NOT
your doctor because you can say not a
doctor you are
that's hilarious well what's up Tony
Robbins I am NOT your mentor oh yeah
let's get your Netflix I'd love to see
you understand what another awesome
statistic fee that Daniel sloth game
sloth don't feel sloth gave me and video
guiding with it to record jigsaw and
dark for Netflix single show hour and a
half ish or so of recording 40 grand
each per episode forty thousand pounds
to record an hour like 90 minutes
so that's nowhere near as much as I
thought it would be what to record a 90
minutes of stuff 40 grand and to get it
on Netflix no just to record it like the
cost of the cameras paying all the
actors in there is must be like thirsty
platters it's a comedy special stand-up
show of him on his own uh I thought you
meant dark the like
the German TV show of No so it's a
thought were you thinking no no so it's
a comedy comedian stand up on stage 90
minutes just him recorded to the spec
that Netflix require it to be done at
and then he did it and what he did was
he defended it out of his own pocket did
that flex pay ahead of time no so he was
doing this and it hadn't even been
picked up by Netflix so Bayes agent was
like look like [ __ ] you do mr. you do
new routine he doesn't new routine every
year so look you need to what so you
make it to the spec of Netflix just in
case they put in a bit in case they
wanted and that's what he did that's how
any done both of these things and
apparently like the last show of the
tour and it was the one that he'd
recorded for jigsaw pretty much like
that day or the next day golf stage
called from Netflix we want it and the
way that they did it they will once they
accept that they want it they'll front
you the cash because now everyone's got
80 grand lying around and they said 120
grand for you you know thank you very
much
cost me 80 pushed it back to them like
took the money gave him the videos Wow
so they would presumably people that are
going broke by making production out of
working capital essentially that must be
actually yeah so is that so it was in
that instance but is that is there no
woody gave them the balance back no no
things we jump into after what I think
but is there any other game from having
a show on Netflix what massive exposure
ladies is that it Conan O'Brien and so I
don't whether he actually gets paid for
I'm gonna I say well you don't have to
buy it they'll have to buy the thing I
wondered so so Darren brown is a good
example of this I had a bunch of channel
4 documentaries and has put them all on
Netflix now and then he's done his most
recent one for Netflix yeah so how is
that maybe it's not dirt maybe it's like
it's the chance for a legal team that
then because they own the rights to
distribution it won't be Darren the only
where I sell is going to definitely work
and then also Spotify if you're a band
on Spotify do you get paid by listen
minutes yeah so yeah paper stream but
it's a it spins it's a tiny tiny tiny
tiny
but it just all feels very much like the
because if it's not in it for the
contact reduces the quality contents
just can apply over time well that's all
them but especially it just becomes the
buyers market for content like if
Netflix have a monopoly on on content
that's what I yeah you can sell you your
stand-up showed Hulu stand-up or
whatever it no one's gonna care and so
then people start putting in bids and
broking themselves potentially buy
because there must be sure that don't
make netflix but they've recorded it to
the specification don't you think I
think based on what Daniel was saying
the way that he did it is very alien
like most people fronting it and having
such a big dick
that they think I haven't been asked to
record this but I'm so confident in my
quality that I'm gonna hit a way to make
it and he done it as they had no hedge
that this he's doing it anyway those
need zeros not his recording not at the
spec in that fit right she was taking a
small risk he's taking a lot like I
don't think he did like he wasn't he was
recording them but put them out on
YouTube but he wasn't it would have been
like five grand or something probably
two and got it done like who was really
annoyed at Daniel's lost for the the
wine DMACC in comment on Twitter do you
remember where he was like I saw
arrogant to assume that I with all the
people in the world there's only one of
them that's good enough for you
why did your neck n yeah like certainly
a lot of people got cross a lot of
people and with the views are picking up
there's this weird thing that YouTube
does where it's like there's a little
hump that you've got to get over and we
did it with Sargon um it's happened with
Daniel as well now and it's like it just
sort of trickles along trickles along
and then it just gets over this Ridge it
was just [ __ ] free wheels away so
we've done like more than 50% of the
views over the last couple of days even
though it's been up for like nearly two
weeks now it's whether because we have
that with our videos like the videos
that have a lot of views keep getting
views and videos that have no views get
no views it's true so they're very yeah
this is one for maybe video Mandy can do
a cameo X but usually the
and you can't see him when he comes in
from the camera nothing happens anyway
it's up to finish you just be code yeah
it's the lines of matrix code what else
have we got that's coming up we're gonna
do life hacks
maybe relationships if we wanna fall key
no need to do Instagram Instagram phone
oh yeah like I think we've got enough
for a life fails as well a few so I've
got it yeah you got nothing
oh it's too fast yeah I've got under
life fails I had one it came to me in
the same way of being coping and keeping
a life hacks diary than keeping a life
fails diary the life fail came to me no
to the dev I was in the gym I was like
brilliant I've got one because I didn't
have any nobody down in the gym went
back to trace you know it down on did
you have your iPod shuffle just uh notes
just on your phone yeah okay so you go
to the gym now I need to for programming
which is slightly lower weights I'm
pretty good I'm still quite like did you
know that necessary yeah could've done
but even while you and I on some degree
see that double tap um that's a selling
point and son Stanley Siri you don't
even have to do that and I've got life
fails and I've gone back and I've had a
look and I've just written the word anal
God and I'm like but you about to say
forgotten yeah you know I hate when that
happens sometimes I'll like I'll be like
ah I've got an appointment on the
calendar so I guess the the date just
right 9:00 a.m. 21st April and then you
get to the time you're like oh this
could be the best example of that is
what you told me that you went to see
you sir Ames sat eating a bowl of
spinach and you know why you think spend
a nice s facto nose on my calendar well
well because I trust the research that
passed use if it's done but surely it's
so it's like when we go it's like we go
to coop and you order our chicken and we
know why do not you say what's because I
need to eat more because you can't just
if you just have spinach the one time in
a bowl
no but they do just eat more when you're
out coop like that's surely that means
to chilakamma habits yeah yeah but I
mean say what would have been probably a
little bit more accurate would have been
how to remind to come up as I arrived to
your house saying remember to eat and
you'd have been like
what how much why when like at least the
anal thing would have been like it would
have prompted me at least hunt of being
able to remember what I was talking
about but I have no idea what it is
so make him actually or may not this aim
will not trigger anything cuz anals not
it can't write about me I don't think it
is about anal I think it must have I
must have written something
it sort of corrected it to anal and then
I've so I don't know whole corner
lossless t9 is nip remember the old like
no texting
all right cool [ __ ] and anal are all the
same combination of home knowledge of
stuff like this Jesus Christ right thank
you very much for watching please do not
forget press subscribe share the
episodes propene fitness comm will be
linked in the show notes below and make
sure that you go and check out what you
go and check out go check out the
episode with Rory Sutherland from a
couple of weeks ago that's gear like
thank you
[Music]